we are hosting our first ever live
streamed graduate QA tonight we're gonna
be talking about for those of you that
aren't familiar with our programs our
graduate certificate portfolio so we
offer a number of courses in school of
engineering at Stanford online and
remotely for working professionals to
take to earn graduate credit and it
grade and eventually our undergraduate
certificate or maybe even transfer and
move on to a master's degree at Stanford
in the future so we have two of our
great students here tonight who are
gracious enough to share their time with
us and share their experience being
working professionals taking these
courses and just share you know what are
they plan to do with it what does their
expense experience been like being an
online student as a just reminder to
those of you who are remote right now we
are using pull everywhere which is like
a polling service there's a link in the
YouTube description for those of you
here I wrote it up on the white board
you can go and submit questions you can
upvote questions that you really want to
hear about and we'll try our best to
kind of cover everything that people
want to know so why don't we start with
just having each of you introduce
yourselves where you currently work and
what some of the coursework you've
completed through us has been yeah sure
everybody so my name is Beth Kirsch well
I work locally I work in Palo Alto we
work for a start-up it's a stealth mode
startup not too far from here I work as
a technical director there of AI so the
coursework you know has been following
that trajectories have been you know
with the program for almost a year now
year and a half and taken a bunch of
courses in yeah
2 to 4 n to 3 1 and and right now I'm
enrolled it 2 to 1 n which is the
artificial intelligence principles and
techniques so pretty much the courses
have been geared to what I you know do
at work and even what I wanted to do at
work before I you know started this line
of of endeavor so it's been my journey
so far and you know it's pretty exciting
so far I work in Sunnyvale for a credit
union as a Compliance Manager so I'm
always been the non tech
in my classroom in all my classes I've
taken about nine classes through a CPD
from stats international security and
somewhat MSE a course is management
science and engineering yes MSM yes yeah
so maybe is just like a follow-up
question what motivated you to start
taking coursework through SCPD yeah I
guess I always wanted to do my Master's
right I mean but before I actually you
know jumped into you know that
commitment of you know actually doing a
master's I want to see what graduate
courses were like so I think I see PD
give that when you you know that that
avenue to explore sky almost like
describe some of these these courses
because before you know committing
full-time into it and especially I think
being a full time professional you know
having like 60 80 hour work weeks right
you always have this fear if you can you
know really commit that time and you
know dedication to committing you know
fulfilling a full-time masters or even a
part-time master so I think this was a
was a good opportunity to just get that
get that experience and and just to try
it out for myself if that's something I
wanted to do so and I think that that
the program just fit in I mean it just
worked to my aspirations and and that
was the primary motivation to start
something like this yeah I started out
because what to complement continuing
education for my work
so I started I used to work for a
regulatory agency and I wanted to learn
more about financial models so I started
with taking a stats course that covers
financial models and then once I took
that course I just kind of looked at the
menu of offering and saw like how many
great courses and then at the faculties
that have speedy offers so I ventured
out to international security programs
because I always had you know interested
in international affairs and and I
wanted to learn more and you know what
this was
perfect opportunity to do that where you
get to listen to all the renowned
faculties including former deputy
director of national intelligence and
from ambassadors from Russia and
Afghanistan so and I and then I think I
ventured into it he was saying so and
what more can I do here and next thing
was the natural progression was going
into masters and before I come in I
wanted to try out so I started taking
MSN courses to see if it's a good fit
for me and so far it's been and I
actually applied for next year Oh
awesome well that's that's a great
follow up question so now that you've
been taking courses how has this
affected kind of your career goals or
your academic goals okay well I think
one thing it benefitted me for my career
wise is I actually tried to apply to
some of the things I learned during
class like for instance like I took
office management course and during the
class we learned the real valdine
principles and I actually try to learn
more about that little bit more about
and actually try to apply that in my job
so and seeing how I could apply like
what I'm actually learning from
classroom to my work you know and seeing
more opportunities to do that to this
class or the program so yeah yeah I'm
gonna go a little bit of what you said
because I think so I've been in the
industry for a decade and you know a lot
of what you know I've learned is you
know what I've used before you know some
of these courses as well but I think the
differentiating factor is you know the
the field changes the field evolves
right any feel of engineering or science
you know keeps evolving and I think
being connected to to the latest and
greatest that's happening in in academia
and bringing that back to the industry
is extremely critical especially in
these times and Ages where you know
research makes us so fast from lab to
production so I think one of the most
lucrative factors of you know getting
connected back to academia was you know
while you know
you know in a profession rate which
requires you to be on the bleeding edge
of technology but how do you how do you
you know instrument yourself back into
that you know that framework of you know
learning and application so I think you
know having what what essentially I
noticed in terms of you know my career
goes was you know we the fundamentals
are all you know the same but what what
really advances you is the connections
that you make in the both you know in
academia and then through that to that
explosion you know the the literature
the science that you get exposed to and
I've seen that a lot of what you know
that that have been exposed to over the
years has translated back to to the work
workplace and so we've been able to
connect you know you know in the
research to to actual application which
is which has been very yes it's been
very beneficial and you also I think
told me earlier that you're also
applying to a master's program it was
very fired that's right
so not both of you applied that's
awesome so just to give some context for
people who don't really understand the
connection between these two programs
all the courses you take in a graduate
certificate you can transfer up to
eighteen units of that coursework to a
master's program at Stanford if you are
admitted if you apply and are admitted
to a program so this is a really great
example for both of them of how they've
taken courses and it kind of inspired
them to maybe apply to actually pursue a
degree and now they can actually take
the coursework if they're admitted and
transfer it toward their degree and be
kind of ahead and completing it and
maybe another great segue to talk about
once you were in these courses what was
it like balancing work and studying cuz
I think that's the thing most people are
concerned about is how I'm gonna go back
to school and maintain my job yeah I
think that's a good question and it's
there's no easy answer to that because I
think it's yeah I mean for I think
initially it's like anything weird I
mean it's it's it's it's you have to you
know invest a lot at the start
I mean it takes a little bit of getting
used to in managing I don't say managing
time is more like managing priorities
because you know you have limited time
right so you know how do you fit your
priorities in that time so I had you
know you have to rebalance stuff so yes
you know initially you have to give up a
little bit of your weekends
you know you have to you know maybe put
in some extra you know effort after work
and you know just I guess go through the
go through the motions until you you get
to a place where you know you're you're
now more you know I guess efficient and
an adaptive to the coursework so the
cause essentially I think write a
beautifully designed because you know
everything that is required for the
coursework is a available online so a
person like me you know who so initially
now I work very close to school but for
doing the first year I was almost like
25 miles away from school so it was very
hard to you know come in all the time
right so it's it's really I think the
way these courses are structured as you
know most of the collaboration can
happen online and that's helped a lot I
mean especially the the even just simple
things like the quality of the the video
right and the actual engagement in there
off so that that is helped but also you
know the other forums like I think the
the meetings a pianist the Piazza Piazza
is really good actually you can I mean
I've never had my question you know not
answer like within the first couple of
hours of posting it so I think
somebody's always on it so I think for
the most part if you really want to make
it work you know you can it's just just
going to the initial hurdle of you know
getting things into motion yeah I mean
like I said the technology makes it very
interactive even though it's online
class like Piazza or website that that
faculties user th use you can interact
with different students you can interact
with different students to Google+
Google Google hangout at Skype I've done
study groups with people in France and
we try to make it work
so I think because the way SPD runs the
program it makes it work for you so that
and and and also make it meaningful at
the same time and as far as the time
made me for me was I try to select the
course that I really wanted to learn not
something that I will have to take so if
you are doing something you really like
you just make time to do it so it's I
think that's why I did it yeah
yeah what you need to talk about some of
the great parts of remote learning what
has been a challenge and being a remote
student I guess for me is not being able
to interact live time so but I take
recently a lot of the TA started office
hours using Google hangout or Skype so
they're available each week to actually
interact with you through like taste
like face chatting and things like that
so it's been that's been helpful and
benefit of me being living close by I
actually attend classes when I can so I
can actually interact with peers and
then Faculty's yeah I think for me and
this is more on me because just having
the time to make it to study sessions
and group something although you know
it's been easy to form groups but just
to keep up to you know coming to campus
and you know or meeting somewhere else -
for me we've had online online you know
meetings and collaborations which is
good but I think just being in here in
person sometimes you know I have to wait
like maybe a couple of days to get the
answer which I could have probably
gotten right there yeah so yeah and I
think asking the professor a question
during an online session is not possible
so yeah personally not yet you just
started piloting technology where we can
live stream the courses but that doesn't
enable live participation I mean even as
we're seeing now this is us trying to do
live participation and even that's not
as as great as it is if you're
physically here to raise your hand right
so it's something we're working on but
but you are right like that can
definitely be a challenge what are some
tips you would give to a new student to
be successful in their first course I
think I was resolved what what you said
what you said because I think not the
most important thing to be successful is
to really enjoy what you're doing right
so most people I am assuming who take
SCPD or you know respective courses they
really want to they really either are
working in that field that they are
taking to studies or want to work right
or some combination thereof so I think
it's very important
to tie your y2 to what you're doing
because otherwise it really becomes
really becomes a drag right so please
personally for me I wanted to make sure
that you know the so my course is align
really well with what what I do so I
think it just becomes an extension of
work in that way but something that I
want to work on kind of thing process is
what you have to do at work so yes I
think that's number one
to be you know I guess successful I mean
there are so many other things but I
guess also you know just you know trying
to you know keep up with the coursework
I mean just make sure that you know you
participate I think participation is key
in in you know in discussions in forums
you know and some of the in Piazza in
Piazza is really awesome if you use it
really well so yeah and some of the
starter tips and I remember more I think
of that yeah I mean that you want to add
her what I mean like you said like I
guess try to find passion in learning at
Stanford through the course offerings
and
and then an another thing is always form
a study group does it help me a lot
I'm a business major no no math
background or net no tech ground so that
has been especially challenging for me
taking some of the courses with taking
advanced statistics course or
programming courses so the study group
have helped me greatly getting one
learning from bouncing off each other
and also getting a decent grade yes so
what has been one of the best parts of
taking courses through SCPD I guess the
people you meet like the faculty so you
meet and then the people you get to
interact with like everybody is smarter
than me and where do you get to meet
people like that word and interact with
people who are much smarter than you and
and also speaking towns away yeah yeah
can I say two best parts yeah I think
the first is the faculty I mean you
exposed to some really legends in the
industry I mean you name the course
right I mean you're talking about books
but nebs you know I Claire publications
and they're like on like the keynotes of
like one of the most inspiring you know
switch is you know off your domain so
that's that's really good and having
access to those people like you could
literally walk up to them and ask them a
question
right I mean that's that's that's really
if you know when you're in like tier
sessions or something so that's that's
been really encouraging and you know
just getting you know feedback on and
then I think the TA group is really
awesome they do a really hard work and
help support you apart from that I think
one really good pot I like about SCPD is
the collaboration the projects because
those are like really you can
collaborate with Stanford students
full-time and then you know two or three
and do poster sessions and projects and
that you really work with a group here
and you know you you make something of
value and and and so many times those
turn into like publications or project
you know project reports that are really
useful their office bell so I think I
love the projects that we do as part of
recipe awesome how does a student make a
successful connection with a course
teaching team while studying remotely
just participate in the office hours
they're available yeah I think office
hours are a key I mean if you can come
in for you know personally that's
awesome if not you know there is like a
at least for my course that's like a
weekly office power that for a CPD
students which is which is equally
engaging and the technology is good you
have like a I forget the name of that
queuing system but there's like you
could really you don't have to like hang
up on the line you can just put in your
queue and you know you're you can yeah
it's just really nice the technology
supports you know just collaboration the
sky videos and Google paints and all
that but beyond that I think also
connecting with as many I guess cap on
camera students helps because then
you're building those connections and
you know you're doing you know projects
together or reports together even study
groups together have you been able to
maintain any of those connections you
make yeah students yes absolutely
actually pretty much through every
course that I've done so far you know we
had been keeping in touch and and one of
the projects we are actually actively
collaborating this is almost a year
after the course ended already you've
been able to keep it yes they're on my
LinkedIn Facebook friends there you go
networking opportunities what's
something you wish you'd known before
you started taking courses there a CPD
workload Monica so to be really honest
right so some of the courses and we were
talking about this up line as well some
of the courses are intense right and
then you know they all like four or five
units but it really it's the math
doesn't work directly right I mean in
some courses they're manageable and you
can really get to them you know along
with you know and expect what you expect
in terms of putting in an hours per week
lis but some ones are you know like
require almost one and a half times the
effort which which kind of you know
throws are some of your some of you know
calculations so I think one of the
things you know would be to you know
kind of just go to the syllabus and you
know make sure that you know you that's
something that you can manage with your
current workflow I think that will
definitely help you know reduce some of
that yes John yeah
like me I mean this is not a stamp for
extension like you see a by extension
right you are you have opportunity to
take classes with full-time graduate
students so there are intense I mean for
me mature the classes were intense
because I didn't have math or tech
background but again the students help
and Faculty's help as long as you do
your work the carving is great so as
long as you're where you're gonna get
your great so there you go yeah maybe
speaking just thinking about your work
experience your professional experience
how have your companies that you've been
at value this certificate or this
coursework as opposed to you know just
coming in with a master's degree and you
know do you think it makes a difference
at all I think a lot of employers are
very supportive of these things so I've
been working I've worked at a lot of
corporations now at the startup so
throughout the course work I think you
know in terms of supporting financially
these employers have supported the cost
of the course and I think we have a CPD
has partnerships - yes yeah we have
certain partnerships and depending on
the billing situation if you are getting
some sort of employer base funding we're
very flexible with helping like support
that mode of payment like we don't
require only a credit card if we have a
voucher or a company is gonna send a
check for you you know we're very
accommodating to that because we do
recognize that people are getting
tuition sponsorship from different modes
than just their own personal personal
income right so yes I guess it's it's
been supportive and I think also I think
the value you bring back from these
courses translates to I mean I don't
know if there's a really hard you know I
guess correlation there but I think it
just helps you in terms of you know
advancing your career I mean in terms of
you know just getting better roles at
Network you know
better projects maybe a promotion
what-have-you I don't know but yeah I
think for sure I think it helps Rodya
subcontracts to
see for me you know I didn't know you
know having a certificate program on
your resume would actually help you
because I recently changed my job and
through that process one thing I noticed
was they don't care whether it's this
master's program or certificate program
they only in the cast members name and
that goes a long way and and I actually
noticed that I was kind of surprised
that they actually oh you went to
Stanford
well it's a certificate program but well
doesn't marry you wants tempering so
it's I think it does carry weight
career-wise I mean I don't think either
of you in our time talking have talked
about making any drastic career shift
while doing these programs but do you
think you know if you were trying to
kind of change your specialization or
what you're doing you could leverage the
specific coursework you took to do that
I mean if you combine your experience
and coursework here I think it
definitely will help you to go to the
route whichever route you take because
they recognized and named it this gives
the credibility I think so yeah no I
yeah I think it's been a little bit more
I guess concrete in my case because you
know especially in the in the a I feel I
mean a lot of what is required in the
market out there is is it's covered in
these course works right so I think it's
more to I guess this is direct
correlation of having some of these
courses on your on your resume to you
know just I guess having a better
opportunity so I think it depends on you
know what I guess the trajectory of your
career is but I think in some cases that
these directly correlate yeah we could
get a question kind of around what is
the average class size or the amount of
students we have every every quarter and
I can speak just from an administrative
side you know I would say autumn and
winter quarters are biggest but we're
usually getting you know 800 to a
thousand students remote each quarter
and but that doesn't even include the
on-campus enrollment with all the
matriculated students so I'm kind of
curious in your experience definitely
for you being in the larger si s classes
has
and I mean is there any like pros and
cons to that or what is your experience
Bend be these large classes and maybe if
you've been in smaller ones you can
speak to maybe a difference of that yeah
I think on an average my class size has
many 800 so it's definitely a huge huge
class size I'm not necessarily if it if
it really makes any any any difference
because you know at the end of the day
you know being a remote student right I
think you still have the access to the
material you know this is the same way
so and you know for a thing it's a
little bit better for benefit for a CPD
students because you know I think you
have your own office hours which is you
know not that that huge right so I don't
know that I have really necessarily
faced any any cons as a matter of fact
you know for even the midterms you you
know initially I did not know that I
thought I had to do an exam monitor but
I about take always taking my midterms
over to campus which is which is good
because you know it's it's for me it's
better taking class than you know yeah
home so yeah I don't think it's mattered
that much please in my case yeah yeah I
mean I've taken courses where I was one
of 300 remote students I have taken
other courses where I was one of two so
in a smaller setting you know the
professor's actually interact with you
they know you by first name basis and we
interact on Piazza and they usually
respond right away so you have better
interaction and larger classroom you
have larger pool of people you can
recruit to build your study group so a
lot of times in those classes I normally
started with like 20 people in a study
group and then a team or left with maybe
five but throughout the process you're
you're getting help from all those
people so and I think one thing I had
noticed with Stanford classes they they
set you up to work in Kings seems like
they reinforced you to work in a team
outside classroom and sometimes you
learn more from
the study group stand in classroom
because that sometimes I think is
designed that way but I don't know but
at some time it came out that way yeah
that's great um we had one question that
just came through that I can take it was
about many non CS classes still require
a programming background or some kind so
for those of us without that background
how how would we get that does that's
maybe we offer we do offer some
lower-level CS courses CS 106 a and 106
B which are like the introductory
programming courses we've also
introduced a few self-paced non-credit
courses that are like intro to data
science like an R course
Python course so those are some options
i I would say that the departments are
also very open to other online courses
that you're doing at home if that's
something that works better for you to
kind of supplement this prerequisite
knowledge they just look to see the U of
A certificate or something showing that
you actually did the work so definitely
don't be prohibited from applying in the
future you know we you're welcome to
email us and we can take a look at your
transcripts and and work with the
Department say okay you wouldn't be
approved right now but if you did this
in this and got X grade or showed this
certificate we can definitely you know
approve you to take the course so you
know don't feel discouraged just because
it seems like there's a lot of
engineering courses that require higher
level prerequisites there's still a lot
of ways that you can still get that and
we'll try to support you to still end up
in the course you want to be in so
definitely just always communicate with
us and we can we can help along the way
maybe as like another question what is
your have you noticed that now since you
live in the area you're mostly trying to
come to class to meet with TAS or
professors and have you ever like you
said you were 25 miles away when you
first started like did you take your
classes exclusively online and was that
how was that experience just being
purely online yeah the first I guess the
first first course was exclusively
online and I think I mean you you
definitely I mean I personally have
benefited a lot coming to campus because
now that I'm closer and it just helps
build connections with people and you
know folks that you work on a project
basis or a classroom basis even study
sessions for that matter but even taking
exclusively online at
it's it's a different experience I mean
you think you gear yourself to you know
address the coursework in that sense so
you know just one thing about taking
classes online right is that you can
actually pause and play the video when
you want to which is which is you know
you can't do that in my class so I see
myself seeing myself going back and
forth and you know taking a lot more
notes when I'm doing it online versus
kind of you know being here but again I
think it's just a different experience
so I think is really hard to quantify
which one is better but I think at the
end of the day I think you know what you
what you gain from you know mmm I guess
from from both of them it's just
different so I know if I I prefer one
versus the other but yes do you answer
your question I do see myself coming to
campus more often now that I'm in the
area yeah yeah you know yeah it's more
better over there
yeah and definitely all these courses
can be done completely remotely I think
that was part of the point of this event
is to show that you know you can do this
at a distance and still get access to
all the great benefits of these Stanford
courses have to offer I don't know if
you had anything to add to that either
again that I think it's beneficial to
have that option to come but there's
pros and cons you said like math
intensive courses I get to pause the
video and take know where they're all
the students in class and I see them
struggling to take notes
so to being you and I see a lot of full
times to now have access to that speedy
recording so today I see them la using
that as well for their benefit that's
going back is being able to just go back
and listen again and for preparing for
midterm or final you can go back to a
lecture and just listen to that again
and I travel a lot so I watch lectures
on plane at the airport or you know in
uber so things like so this that the
online class I'm setting kind of gives
you the flexibility so it's beneficial
for people who's working yeah and a few
hours yeah
what are like some just tips I mean
you've obviously talked about using the
recordings and pausing them and take
better notes as helpful is there any
other just study tips that you would say
to someone taking one of these courses I
think one of the things that helped me
initially was you know just want you to
be a note-taker that was good because
you know you kind of force yourself to
be disciplined and in terms of taking
notes and you know just being more
involved with the curriculum so you know
once you do that it kind of that kind of
helped me at this charge so if you know
somebody wants to be a note-taker you
just helps them to be more involved with
the program initially now I have not
done it for the last two courses but I
think that was one good experience the
other tips I guess yeah I think the
office hours are under emphasize so I am
gonna be emphasize that and I think
they're really really beneficial and
coming back to you know just kidding I
think it just sometimes you know being a
remote student you're working through
problems and you know it's just let's
say it's a math problem or what have you
you just get stuck in a loop and you
know you keep attempting it and you know
maybe you just end up more spending more
time than you want to just bringing that
back to office hours or you know
remotely collaborating helps I think is
having building as many connections has
really been you know one of the success
factors of you know this whole program
also unless you're Stephen Hawking's you
don't do office hours if you don't do
study group
if you don't ask a lot of questions it's
hard to succeed I mean you know I said
they curve the grade so I think getting
a B is pretty easy as long as you do the
work but getting an A is extremely hard
so you have to do push yourself to get
an A or A plus in all these classes so
if you don't do all those three you know
then you won't it would be hard to be
successful in this class that's good to
know that's real to real talk right
there I'm gonna take you guys back to
when you were first deciding to apply to
do coursework what was the application
experience like any I mean pain points
are any tips for students that you would
give who want to start applying
winter quarter yeah I guess for me even
before I think the before I decided to
go into like a more graduate program I
took a few courses that were unrelated
to the current you know program that I
am doing there was some business courses
and stuff so that was that was pretty
straightforward I mean II think it was
just going to the website and and
applying it I'm not sure if this was
true has to be probably it was true if
it's like a professional
yes exactly yeah so I think that kind of
gave a little bit of a I guess teaser as
to you know how things are and those
were really good courses as well the
probably one to two units max but then I
think when I finally decided to you know
be serious and go you know with a
specific program I think you know it was
pretty I think streamline I mean it was
essentially going to the website getting
information I think corresponding with
the CBT staff was really helpful because
you know they were very responsive I
mean that usually you need email you
wait for a week or something before you
get a respond but I was pretty happy
about the response time then in general
the responsiveness of the the folks and
then I think just in terms of
eligibility was just a matter of
submitting your transcripts and you know
a few more questions and you know I
think it was not that hard it's pretty
straightforward
so they yeah I think it was you know
more or less seamless to begin with and
did you feel that way even once you were
approved to take your first course did
you feel like the transition into your
class and all the different systems and
accounts that Stanford has how does that
experience yeah I think it took a little
bit to get used to that I mean
especially you know I kind of like miss
initially when I I wanted a certain
course but then I kind of waited like a
week after it was announced and it was
gone so you know you've got to be 10 top
of your registrations because some of
these courses are so popular you know
you're probably in a week's time they
are all fall right yeah you're on the
waitlist
yeah and I would say particularly with
your experience with artificial
intelligence of courses those tend to be
the ones that fill up within the first
week first few days of enrollment
depending on what they are so I would
definitely say you know if there's a
course that you know you want to take
don't hesitate submit the application
enroll or just you know call us and let
us know and we can reiterate please in a
role like like get this done because
then we have exactly what happened to
you if people who are like well I want
to take this course and now it's full
and it's online there's unlimited seats
right and it's like well no someone has
to green so yeah definitely I would I
echo everything you said right and I
think the good part is there's also like
a you know you can try the course and if
you change your mind you can always you
know figure out you know what you know
if you want to take another course or
something so that's an option too yeah
but I think beyond that you're counting
the systems and stuff I think I think
Piazza was pretty helpful yeah getting
on it was just signing up so yeah I
don't think there was any major issues I
think we're just going a little bit back
and forth with the staff to clarify some
of the questions so I'm glad that
there's somebody who's you know
dedicated to this function so that you
know you don't figure out everything
yourself
now we had like a few questions in there
but just to start again what was your
application and enrollment process like
as far as the application process I
thought it was getting much harder being
is still Stanford right and I applied I
had to provide a transcript idea to
write a short essay that's right and
within hours like hey you're approved
that is not an hour well he was pretty
fast I thought it was gonna be they're
reviewing application and going through
a different process but it was it was a
matter of hours of reading days
I got approval and as far as
prerequisite that is the business major
I didn't meet any prerequisite you know
business majors you just need to add and
subtract all right so I didn't have to
do a car coulis or anything like that so
I had to do all the calculus all the
computer programming prerequisite and
they were very helpful because I just
found this unknowns Community College
down south and I started taking courses
I provided the coursework to this PD and
they said yes that's fine it was just
you know same day it's like okay you can
take that would accept it and then they
accepted everything and I was able to
meet all the prerequisites to take some
of the courses and as far as the
technologies I think that's where also
where the
interacting with EAS as students is
important because like at first they're
like they're throwing these okay this is
on campus and this is on Piazza so it
was canvassed in Piazza but then you got
to interact with people to find out
where the canvas what is canvas and how
to use it and it was Piazza and what how
to use Piazza you know because there's
no manual to use it you just have to
learn it on your own and it everywhere
that's helpful you just have to ask the
question yeah yeah and I would say you
know to echo I mean I guess this makes
me look biased but I would say we have a
good response time to email so if you're
having any confusion about our
application our enrollment system or you
know once you're in a course where what
is canvas what is Piazza how do I get my
Stanford email you know those are all
things that our team is here to do I
answer a lot of those emails every day
so we're definitely trying to make it as
easy a process as possible especially
because you are a remote you can't just
show up to your adviser or to your
professor and say I don't understand
what's going on so we try to be really
mindful of that in our response times
and just also reiterate about the
application process we try to keep it as
simple as possible yes these are
Stanford courses but unlike applying to
a master's program you know if you're
qualified to take the course and you've
you've enrolled on time and sent the
application and the transcripts you'll
most likely be approved the department's
just want to make sure qualified people
are in there but they're not like we
only admit 30 percent you know and we
try to get you answers as fast as
possible it usually takes a few weeks
from when you apply and enroll and and
I'll mention this again at the end of
the the presentation but winter quarter
enrollment is open so if you know this
presentation sold you you can just get
right into it and apply and probably
enroll by the end of this week that's
how easy it is so yeah definitely I
would exit out we try to keep it as
simple as possible and and also improve
our communication around all the
different platforms and systems because
that is something we recognize can be a
little confusing for a new student or
someone that hasn't been in college for
a while so we got a new question that is
asking how you
saina to take courses here at Stanford
rather than another online platform like
Coursera or audacity or things like that
yeah I think that's that's a very good
question I mean I did take online
courses like audacity or Coursera but I
think personally what I've felt with
online courses is I personally cannot
find myself to commit to them maybe it's
a force function maybe it's Stanford
maybe it's you know the the Association
of folks are on here maybe it's the
group study I personally am NOT a big
fan of you know what do you call them
nice acronym or self-paced sucks yeah
yeah so yeah I mean maybe it's maybe
it's a personal thing but for me to
succeed and be focused and you know
provide you know my best I think I need
to be involved with a group of people
who I can see you know and and know and
and I think shantou provides you kind of
like all of that with with like you know
the flexibility of doing it when you
want to do it which is which is I mean
pretty which is very hard to find in
online courses so yeah also the just is
you know I think the best part I like
about this course is your schedule is
aligned with the with the full-time
students so that way you know you have
your now accountable to not just you
know your yourself but to the group that
you're working with so it's it's time
bonded and you know for some of the
online courses even though they are
time-honored this doesn't work the same
way yeah about you for me is like
whether you take a course at Stanford or
a MOOC or a Coursera I think you have to
still commit your time to do it and I
guess you have to think about what's
more meaningful to you and just by
looking at the people the stanford
program attracts and then the faculties
they offer like where do you go learn
about us-russia relationship from former
ambassador to Russia right so it is that
list goes on and on so so then you have
to think about if you're gonna commit
your time you know what is more
meaningful to you like or what it was
more worth to you you know so
yeah awesome um I think we're kind of
Nassar need to get into repetitive
questions around balancing work but is
there anything else that you'd like to
share about your experiences as a remote
student oh I guess in terms of balancing
work I think it's always gonna be a
challenge I mean it's there's always
going to be different challenges at
different points in time one because
these courses you know span over years
right I mean if you really serious about
doing like a like a master's program you
know then you're talking about a couple
of years right before you so I think
it'll be in different points in life at
that point so I think keeping your I
guess your goal Center to what you want
and then you're working a life or on
that is is what I do and you know it's
it's definitely hard I mean I won't over
advertise anything you know I mean it
takes a lot of commitment and sacrifice
but I think at the end of the day if
that's what you want you know that's
what your passion then you make it work
I actually have another question for you
guys did you I don't remember your eggs
program flames off the top of my head
but did you guys take courses every
quarter since you've started or have you
taken breaks or what does that look like
I have taken yeah I've taken a break so
I've taken courses for the first so what
I did was for the first two quarters I
took it back to that and then you know I
had to switch my job so I took a break
and then in and I'm in my third course
oh yeah taking a break yeah I took break
to meet take the class for prerequisite
in the middle because in the beginning
the courses did not require prerequisite
of the statistics and the international
security and then I took a break about a
year to take all the cartilage
requirement and then computer program
requirement and I took MSE courses so
I've been taking maybe one to two
classes a quarter depending on the
workload and there are resources
available to find how hard we're
difficult their courses there's a
Stanford student very smart guy created
this website Carta and you can go there
and then you can get all the insights
about the course and average grade and
there is time each student spend for the
course and and you can kind of plan that
according to that so it's using that
some time I decided to take another
course work looking oh this one takes
one hour a week and this one takes one
hour a week and like probably combined
in it in one quarter and in another
course it says three hours a week before
hours a week to only take one so there
are ways that you can kind of plan it
yeah and there resources available and
again just talking to other students and
they will help you so you take this
course and take that course yeah and I
can speak to that too we employ a few
current graduate students and some of
the higher enrollment departments like
management science and engineering
computer science statistics and
electrical engineering and we have
course advisor emails on our website you
can email you know EE course advisor
directly and say hey like I'm interested
in this certificate or this specific
course what does the work will look like
what's a logical order to take the
courses or this is my background what do
you think and they're so knowledgeable
about this that they can give you really
really detailed way better answers than
I could ever give about whether or not
this makes sense for you so that's
definitely something that I recommend
people utilize maybe before deciding on
a course to enroll or you know reach out
to us and we'll well loop them in if we
think it makes sense and then also just
to reiterate what you guys have already
touched on you don't have to take
courses every quarter if you're pursuing
a graduate certificate we give you three
years from when you finish your first
course to finish your certificate so
it's a lot of time usually certificates
only require four courses so you can
really take your time and take quarters
off and and you know like you said use
different resources I don't think I'm
allowed to sanction Carta is like you
should check how many hours your classes
but I do know a lot of students use it
and that can be a really helpful way to
just plan around what's going on also if
you you know if you are in communication
with your managers and maybe you guys
can speak to this more of your
experience working with your manager
through this you know I talked to a lot
of students where they you know said
well work project just randomly came up
and sometimes that's unavoidable and you
have to drop a class and were they
to help you through it but as much as
you can communicate with your your
managers or your work and kind of know
Wellspring has a big project I won't
take a course then summer is gonna be
pretty quiet that's a great time for me
to do something I think that's a great
strategy to employ as well and I don't
know if you guys have like specific
examples of working with your manager
whoever to kind of have support through
this program yeah no I I think I can
talk to that so like for example you
know one of the things you have to plan
is like some of these courses are only
offered in a certain quarter yeah so if
you miss it in the last quarter and you
know you miss it again then you just
have one more year to do it so that a
little bit of planning needs to be done
on your end but I think for me
especially you know during the first
course you know I specifically went up
to my manager and said hey I need your
support here for this quarter I'm doing
this it's pretty intense course and you
know I mean you know requires some
flexible work hours it's not that I'm
not gonna do what you want me to I
probably do more but you know it's just
need your support and you know helping
me if I want to you know maybe go attend
an office hour you know during the work
day and I think generally people are you
know for if you're managers they
couldn't finish it I mean they're
they're fine with it and you know you
can you can work around that
but yeah because I was intentionally
taking classes that were unrelated to my
work cuz and so I was on my own
uh-huh and but you can still make it
work again because cuz I was doing that
because I was actually taking courses
that I want to take on with something I
want to learn about so you know I
actually wanted to make time commitment
to make it work so yeah and I'll just
speak actually on a personal level I
have not taken any courses through SCPD
I just work here but I actually just
started a part-time master's program
myself
and it's kind of on the weekends where I
have to go to the class but even just
doing that I've found that being honest
with my team and with my manager and
saying hey this is what I'm doing
there's gonna be a day when I need to
leave early to get to class or just I
have a big thing to do this week like
you know and also setting that
expectation for myself with school like
I know there are certain weeks when
enrollment
is my main priority for this job and I
kind of need to put my score to the side
so I would say just setting those
priorities with yourself as much as you
can before signing up is really
important life will still hit you but I
think that's for my own personal care
has been really helpful and also to
speak to course scheduling like you were
talking about we it tends to be that
courses are only offered once in the
same quarter each academic year which
can be kind of frustrating depending on
when you start in the year and you want
to be working through a certificate it's
definitely something we're constantly
trying to address because we are filling
courses that are on campus we're kind of
also at the whim of Stanford University
scheduling which if you haven't worked
in that it can be a pain so you know
we're trying to make it as easy to work
through as possible as many offerings as
consistently as possible and I think in
the two years I've been here we've
definitely made improvements on that but
that is something to keep in mind and
and you're welcome again to reach out to
us again say I'm interested in the
certificate when are all the courses
typically offered and we can kind of
give you a tentative idea of what a
program plan might look like or you know
again it might give you a sense of well
Spring Quarter nothing I'm gonna want to
take his offer that's a great quarter
for me to take off you know so again we
can work with you and do our best to try
and give you an idea and set an
expectation of what your plan could look
like yeah and I think you know that's
most of the questions that we had have
had come through I don't know if there's
anything else that you if there have
been an event like this before you
started you would have wanted to have a
question answered or would have been
great to attend an event like this
before I started I think a lot of what
you learned through experience can be
learned you know through some of these
events right so I can't think of any
question that hasn't been happy yeah
yeah what about you do anything you're
going to add it's one thing I would say
is SPD is a great resource and
initiators they you know has questioned
the answer but also the faculties and
TAS are very helpful they are very
accommodating so in some classes they
offer alternate assignments for students
but they understand the challenges of
the world being most
so sometimes when whose time soon we're
taking in classroom
tests they offer us to do like a writing
assignment so that it's more flexible
for us so don't think that you know you
know you have to follow all the rules
sometimes there I think sometimes
they're more lenient towards the growth
students because it is more challenging
so yeah awesome thank you for sharing
that and just when I think I'll note you
know we're wrapping up our session thank
you guys again for being here and
answering all these questions winter
quarter enrollment is open so if you
know you liked what you've heard and
you're interested in learning more and
maybe even taking a course our
enrollment period is currently open
until December 10th the actual quarter
will start January 7th and run till
about mid end of March depending on when
finals are we have a lot of different
courses that are being offered in a
variety of departments not just the ones
we've talked about tonight so please you
know go on to SCPD stanford.edu take a
look at our portfolio please reach out
to us with any questions for those of
you remote there was a few slides that
were posted at the beginning that kind
of reiterated this enrollment
information and for those of you that
are here you know feel free to come and
talk to me about any questions you may
have and if you guys are here for a few
more minutes we can take you know some
more direct questions but yeah thank you
guys so much for coming and for those
online you know thank you for for
listening and trying this experiment out
with us hopefully it's been helpful and
giving you idea of what taking a lecture
there's lectures in this court in this
room all the time so this is actually
just what it's like maybe the question
do oh there's a question yeah
access to TA and the lecturer men versus
what they are here could you go to the
classroom and take part or you had to go
to your sister today and ask your
questions there that you're pretty more
than obviously only activity but itself
right right
there's one question again my next
question
I mean cast knows that you mentioned
that you're taking in those who are
there they take notes but I just wanted
to know I have access to
get dressed I'll just reiterate the
questions for people on line so the
first one I think goes around just can
you only talk to your TA or interact I
so I can speak to that so you're asking
about can I attend the lecture on campus
so those seats are reserved for
matriculated students that being said
you can come to campus for office hours
so if you know there is an on-campus
office hour happening and you're in the
area please feel free to come and also
you know you can reach out to the
teaching teams and if they have their
own kind of like by appointment office
hours again they're more than willing to
accommodate and then I think your second
question was around access to textbook
materials into notes maybe yeah I think
just a point to the first question I
think the other thing is you know as
part of your curriculum you know if
you're doing a project which lasts the
entirety of the quarter or at least 3/4
of the courrier you're a sign like they
can advisor hope that project itself so
you work with some it's empty a you know
so I think that can be a point reference
for you know not just a product but you
can ask questions and they're pretty
open to answer those and although SCPD
has its own office hours but I've never
felt that you cannot go to another
office hours I've always been into just
any office how does that spawn the
calendar so I've been welcome so that's
that's definitely been I'm not taking
classes here because I think it's just
easier for me to do it remotely yeah but
and then also you know I think there's
some logistics there but for the second
question I think as part of every
lecture there's material that's posted
on the course website which includes the
slide deck for that lecture notes for
that lecture and you know even link to
the video and assignments and all that
good stuff so I think between the three
of those resources it's pretty detailed
as to you know I guess what is covered
in that particular lecture but I think
to your point there is still you know
there may be some still details that may
not be captured in those notes so I
think for that I I prefer to just stick
my own notes and you know
cross-reference that more importantly
with
classmates yeah and they're open to
sharing their notes as well so that's
good
anything you want to add her as far as
coming to class in person just ask
cuz I've been to classroom where it was
full so they let you know that you know
they already let you know in advance
that is full and there's no room but a
lot of times there when there's room ta
was say just you're more than welcome to
come so good but I always ask I always
ask what can I come to this class or
this session and and I never got no for
an answer they always said yes but
certain class they will let you know in
the head of time they're there short
with seating and as far as office hours
again just ask they know that you're
working professional and yet challenging
sometimes a lot of people are in
different time zone so if there is
something they can accommodate they will
try to do it and a lot of the tiers are
students just like us so they will try
to work with us right
so one of the things that there had been
start doing is the Google hangout and
Skype so but if you have other medium
that you want to use you can all you
have to just ask yeah awesome
well I think that concludes our panel or
a QA thank you guys so much and I'm
gonna wave so they know that we're no
longer recording
[Laughter]